would he or wouldn't he that is the
question whether tis nobler in the mind
to suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous executive agency overreach or
to take arms against a sea of crooked
bureaucrats and by opposing them before
a foreign dictator and longtime
geopolitical foe and them we will
analyze the question Democrat vultures
and frivolous Republicans are so eager
to keep in the headlines and we will
then a check out has solar power
threatens the lives of a billion poor
people around the globe why
conservatives find more meaning in life
duh and what FDR is unprecedented third
term power grab means for us today on
this day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to talk about it don't I I tried
so hard not to talk about this stupid
mostly Media contrived circus of wit he
wouldn't he would he what what did he
say what did Trump say it's the end of
the Republic
oh no the president that's given us a
booming economy geopolitical stability
deregulation more religious liberty more
original and no now he said something a
little bit wrong and now it's all over
but I do have to cover it because even
frivolous Republicans are really
climbing on and and taking on the
president with much stronger language
than they seem to attack their opponents
on the Left who want to abridge our
Liberty so let's take it on that's fine
here is you know what I'm referring to
I'm talking about President Trump in
Helsinki to pro at the press conference
with President Putin before I can play
it speaking of making making our
geopolitics safer we got to make our
neighborhoods safer we got to make a
little money honey in the meantime let's
talk about ring I want to thank our
sponsors over a ring their mission is to
make neighborhoods safer you know we
need to we need to make sure that the
major nuclear powers in the world keep
us safe and we also need to make sure
that our homes and our packages our
families are safe today over a million
people use the amazing ring video
doorbell to help protect their homes
ring knows that home security begins at
the front door but it doesn't end there
which is why they extend that same level
of security all around the home with the
ring floodlight camera you know this
when you people probably when you're
trying to break into people's homes and
then that flood light comes on and you
scamper away back into the woods well
ring has won that's so good because it
has video so you can you'll see who's
there who's outside who's trying to get
into your house that video goes up to
the cloud so even if the crook goes and
steals the floodlight it's okay the
videos already up there it's the new
neighborhood watch too you can share it
instantly with your neighbors you know
the neighborhood watch is just it's not
a thing anymore now it's much easier
much cheaper much more sophisticated
more likely to keep you safe with rings
floodlight Kim when things go bump in
the night you'll immediately know what
it is whether you're at home let's say
you're at home you just want to talk to
that bad guy outside you can have
two-way a communication through their
video doorbell you can say hey buster
get out of here you you know and so it's
really effective that way or you can be
on a beach and
and you can do the same thing it's
really really effective all my friends
have it I love mine ring floodlight
offers the ultimate in home security
with high visibility floodlights and a
powerful HD camera that puts security in
your hands
save up to a hundred and fifty dollars
off of a ring of security kit today
don't say I never did nothing for you
and seriously go out and get this that
it is really really inexpensive and
provides you peace of mind and a lot of
ease-of-use
even when you're talking to guys who are
just delivering you packages and friends
coming over to visit all the way to bad
guys to keep you safe it's really really
good you need it go to ring.com slash
Knolls KO wles like beyonce ring.com
slash knowles KO wles like Beyonce
that's ring to Hakam / what / Knowles
like Beyonce Jay Z's wife okay let's
talk about it let's just play this clip
right now president Trump is in Helsinki
he makes a remark that maybe it wasn't
the best said here he is
dan coates came to me and some others
they said they think it's Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be but I really
do want to see the server but I have I
have confidence in both parties okay
okay so he says look some people are
telling me that it Russia hacked
everything and some here I'm talking to
Vladimir Putin I don't want to call the
guy a liar he's saying that he didn't do
it
obviously he's denying it he's and by
the way library Putin in that press
conference sort of admits that he's
probably lying right he says I don't
trust the u.s. the u.s. doesn't trust me
I've got my own interests at heart he
was actually pretty blunt about it so
President Trump makes a statement and
people attack it they pillar eeeh do I
think was the best statement no could he
have said it in a better way
sure but you know the guy he's the guy
in the ring was it a is at the end of
the world absolutely not but you had
these conservative critics Newt Gingrich
saying was the worst disaster of his
presidency worst mistake of his
presidency and Newt Gingrich is
typically a trump supporter so this
sounded alarm bells other Trump
surrogates Paul Ryan came out there and
criticized it pretty harshly so
so president Trump issued the most
trumpian apology for this here he is
clarifying clarifying his statements
that I made myself very clear by having
just reviewed the transcript now I have
to say I came back and I said what is
going on what's the big deal so I got a
transcript I reviewed it I actually went
out and reviewed a clip of an answer
that I gave and I realized that there is
need for some clarification it should
have been obvious I thought it would be
obvious but I would like to clarify just
in case it wasn't in a key sentence in
my remarks I said the word would instead
of wouldn't the sentence should have
been I don't see any reason why I
wouldn't or why it wouldn't be Russia so
just to repeat it I said the word would
instead of would and the sentence should
have been and I thought I would be maybe
a little bit unclear on the transcript
or unclear on the actual video the
sentence should have been I don't see
any reason why it wouldn't be Russia
sort of a double negative so you could
put that in and I think that probably
clarifies things pretty good by itself I
have on numerous occasions noted our
intelligence findings that Russians
attempted to interfere in our elections
unlike previous administrations my
administration has and will continue to
move aggressively to repeal any efforts
and repeal we will stop it we will
repeal it any efforts to interfere in
our elections we're doing everything in
our power to prevent Russian
interference in 2018 ok so fine right I
mean that's my take I saw his I saw the
original statement I thought okay well
not great but everything else has been
good and then I saw that and I thought
well okay whatever fine that's fine
because I do like that the walk back and
the clarification was basically
President Trump saying oh well
I see why you misunderstood yesterday
was opposite day you see yes I you must
not have understood this in Helsinki
when I was talking to President Putin
yet it was the opposite day yesterday so
that's it that clarifies it and they
makes a bunch of good points which is
that his administration has been much
harsher on Russia than his predecessor
and he's been harder on President Putin
he's been harder he's been much better
about having allowing the intelligence
agencies to do their job and not
politicizing his executive agencies
what's really pernicious about this
because I actually was sort of cheering
President Trump on when he was refusing
to be backed into a corner and I still
cheer him on I really wish if not for a
few words he really would have had an
excellent performance in Helsinki that's
kind of what caused some of this issue
and there are some reports now that some
people in the White House were saying it
wasn't a great statement but he
shouldn't apologize some people were
saying you know he should get in front
of this right away
whatever this is really a creation of
Democrats in the media and the
bureaucrats led by now mr. Bob Muller I
mean this is a total contrivance and and
Muller bears responsibility here for a
few reasons there's this really pretty
sure aspect of the Muller investigation
which is that it's twofold on the one
hand it's whether Russians hacked the
election whether hacked deal it's a
ridiculous euphemism a ridiculous phrase
whether Russians tried to interfere in
the presidential election as they have
since 1917 yeah probably they did right
the other one is whether President Trump
colluded with Russia and what Muller has
done and what the media have done is
they've conflated these two things so
that President Trump is totally right to
view the Muller investigation as a
political cudgel with which his
opponents are attacking his presidency
why did those indictments come out just
before the the Russia conference isn't
that a little suspect that was obviously
a political move it was a political move
driven by Bob Muller and he deserves
criticism for that I mean that is he's
all this whole time we've heard that Bob
Muller is above politics he's this
figure this totally upstanding guy well
then why is he making such a Naked Lee
political play to release those
indictments right before the Russia
summit that that's that that's on the
one hand now who knows whether you know
I
I take president Trump at his word all
the time but who cares here is what the
real thing that's bothering me is that
these frivolous Republicans who are
clutching their pearls getting so up in
arms about all of this you know what
what do we know about the intelligence
agencies what do we know about them
right now because we're being told how
dare President Trump not you know not
totally accept the word of his
intelligence agencies and officers when
he's speaking in Helsinki well look sure
he's abroad he should you know obviously
should side with his own country over
whatever someone else is saying Russian
dictator is saying but on the other hand
the the federal agencies the
investigative agencies have become
horribly corrupted and politicized what
do we know about them the FBI under
Barack Obama
was used to spy on a political opponents
presidential campaign we know that
happened what do we know from the former
head of the FBI James Comey well when we
look at James Comey right now he is
begging people to vote for Democrats
this man who's supposed to be the last
guy that they told this was above
politics and he's such an upright guy
and he's an honest broker he is now
going on Twitter he said on Twitter
quote all who believe in this country's
values must vote for Democrats this fall
former head of the FBI does that
compromise the integrity of the FBI I
don't know maybe how about the CIA John
Brennan John Brennan is now going on
Twitter saying President Trump is a
traitor
he's treasonous spewing all kinds of
bile John Brennan by the way who voted
for the Communist Party nominee for
president during the height of the Cold
War that John Brennan does that
compromise the integrity of the
intelligence agencies does that
compromise the integrity of our of our
executive agencies yeah I think it does
it's not President Trump who's done that
it's not president Rupp who's turned his
back those guys have done it you know
President Trump and Rand Paul put it
pretty well when it comes in
particularly the case of John Brennan
here there I think Brennan is a very bad
guy and if you look at it a lot of
things happened under his watch I think
he's a very bad person senator you know
I agree completely I think John Brennan
is completely unhinged and you see him
now calling the president treasonous and
what should worry every American is John
Brennan was in charge of the CIA the
most powerful intelligence gathering
you know group on the planet they can
absorb every bit of information you can
imagine your phone calls your metadata
your bank records your visa records they
could destroy any person's life the
person at the head of that turns out to
be a very much a partisan a Trump hater
and very much a just someone who is you
know a Trump hater I guess that's the
best way to put it but you know I really
am worried that he was head of the CIA
for so long harboring all that bias
well said gentlemen I totally agree so
you've got those guys compromising the
integrity of the agencies then you've
got how about Andy McCabe remember him
there are so many scandals that are
coming out right now from the FBI from
high up political appointees over there
that it's hard to keep track of all of
them but Andy McCabe not too long ago
was disgraced and kicked out because he
lied to federal agents under oath this
was a major official how about Peter
struck and Lisa Paige the lover FBI ATF
agents Peter struck is testifying before
Congress he says know those texts the
texts where I said I was going to use
the power of the state to stop President
Trump from becoming president that you
know that didn't mean what you think it
means all you fools you know he looked
like that ghoul that demon on that visa
what do you have to do with me trey
Gowdy I mean it just looked so dishonest
and now we know from his lover at least
a page but who is this has been reported
by a rep John Ratcliffe that she she
contradicts Peter struck statement she
says no those texts mean what they say
they mean they look like that which is
that FBI agents who were investigating
Trump who were in the heart of it who
were on the Mahler team who actually got
fired when this became too public that
those guys were trying to use the power
of the state to stop the Trump
presidency that is a horrifying thing
how about when President Trump met with
Loretta Lynch on the airplane former
head of the Department of Justice under
Barack Obama what about when they met in
and then just coincidentally Hillary got
off the hook shortly thereafter
President Clinton I'm sorry President
Clinton a former future president
Hillary Clinton got off the hook shortly
thereafter and and then what about
Barack Obama we know that he's
politicized other agencies he
politicized the the IRS I mean I was I
was in some
that were targeted by the IRS he used
the administrative agencies to target
his political opponents so okay now
conservatives are clutching their pearls
on this they're say oh no oh no that how
could you ever question these
bureaucratic agencies when did it become
conservative to just blindly defend the
bureaucratic agencies of the federal
government is that conservative now I
don't it's not that not that's not the
conservatism that I learned I don't
think so
there are obviously crooks there and
it's really sad for the rank-and-file
agents because there are a lot of very
good rank-and-file agents there and
their reputations have been tarnished
they've been tarnished because they've
been associated with a crooked bad
actors like Peter struck like Lisa Paige
like like all of these other guys like
James Comey you know Andy McCabe their
reputations have been tarnished it's not
our fault it's not conservatives who did
that and it's not our responsibility to
clean up the mess that was created by
these crooked Democrat officials by
these left wingers who were in positions
of state power and the public trust and
who abused that public trust that's not
our problem
and for conservatives today I know you
can never criticize the intelligence
agencies give me a break that isn't
where sure where's your love of Liberty
come on man
you know also on this why can't
conservatives take yes for an answer
we keep beating up the president you
know he said this he shouldn't have said
that okay and then he says the opposite
and we couldn't take that either just
take yes for an answer keep your eyes on
the prize there is historical precedent
for this by the way people think you
know that history began the day that
they were born or these days that
history began excuse me probably just
yesterday they did this to Ronald Reagan
they did this to Reagan and Gorbachev
Howard Phillips of the conservative
caucus in the 1980s referred to
President Reagan as a useful idiot for
Soviet propaganda does that sound
familiar doesn't Norman Podhoretz
you know a leader in the conservative
movement said that President Reagan
meeting with Gorbachev shamed himself
and the country sound familiar how about
George will George Willa for previously
until recently Republican conservative
columnist he said Reagan went down like
a punctured balloon time flies for
conservatives Ronald Reagan's foreign
policy has produced much surprised but
little delight just attacking him and
then new
Gingrich whom I like and who had just
recently came out pretty strongly
against President Trump for Helsinki he
said in 1985 of Ronald Reagan measured
against the scale and momentum of the
Soviet empires
the Reagan administration has failed is
failing and without a dramatic change in
strategy will continue to fail President
Reagan is clearly failing
he said that meeting with Gorbachev was
the most dangerous summit for the West
since Adolf Hitler met with Neville
Chamberlain in 1938 in Munich guys this
is this has happened before well it
actually kind of makes you feel better
about this moment in history when you
think oh yes this has all happened
before the same hyperbolic ridiculous
statements Ronald Reagan won the Cold
War
Ronald Reagan is the guy who tore down
the Berlin Wall and freed people behind
the Iron Curtain and to hear the things
they were saying about him one wonders
if they'll be saying the same things
about President Trump pretty soon the
other side of this - and then then we'll
move on because there and this actually
has broader implications for history and
for the kind of conservative what we
conservatives should be doing day by day
what it means for us but do people think
that there are just no stakes right now
that it's all just a game I really do
think some people especially some
Republicans or treating this like it's
all just a little game it's all just
about manners and you know whether
they'll be looked on well at the certain
parties and cocktail parties that they
go to or whether you know this old
jockey for the next position or this or
that there are real stakes this is about
liberty this is about freedom you know
Jeff Flake the future former Senator
Jeff Flake
has he called president from shameful a
failure you know just oh is the worst
sort of invective against him and he
tweets this stuff out and then the very
next tweet is a kid you not it's a
picture of Jeff Flake taking a selfie
next to a pig wearing American flag
bunting you know and it's he's making a
joke it says what am i doing this pig
can't even read ha ha ha you know smile
for the camera like are you kidding me
pal do you not realize that there are
stakes here this is what he says like oh
I'm putting on I'm putting on my serious
Jeff Flake face mm-hmm this presidents
awful I want to take him down mm-hmm the
next mint tea look I'm with a pig I mean
it's like they're just they're like
failed Hollywood celebrity
or something you know it's just they
turn it on and off one wonders if some
of these people have core beliefs if
they if they realize oh the the only way
that we can affect a Liberty the only
way that we can increase Liberty the
only way we can reduce government
restriction the only way we can achieve
some modicum of global leadership and
geopolitical peace is through
politicians and through administrations
and the Trump administration has been
very good on this so I'm going to
support that because I want the thing I
don't just want the appearance of the
thing like the left I want the thing
itself
I want the Liberty itself and you got a
wonder if these these sort of frivolous
conservatives like Jeff Flake if they
want that if they have the rise on the
head or if they're just big grinning
teeth and empty suits you you have to
wonder but the people who were actually
affecting policy they're not empty suits
and sometimes they misspeak or whatever
we should give them a little grace on
that and most importantly when they come
out and they apologize and they say no
yesterday was opposite day take yes for
an answer people come on goodness
gracious they're objects here and
speaking of frivolous conservatives I
think there's a parallel here with the
environmental movement there's a real
parallel there's a the same sort of
mistaking the forest for the trees for
getting your priorities all jumbled it
reminds me a little bit of G K
Chesterton he said that heresy isn't the
promotion of Vice it's the promotion of
one virtue to the exclusion of all the
other virtues there's a big story at
today with regard to the environmental
movement Bjorn Lomborg who is the
director of the Copenhagen consensus
Center an environmental think-tank guy
he came out and said pretty clearly in
no uncertain terms that the push among
environmentalists to have to make all
energy you know solar power wind power
renewable energy is a very cruel to 1.1
billion poor people around the world and
a you know his point here is that it's
very easy for us sitting here with you
know in a world powered by oil to say oh
but it would be better if you know we
didn't do that let's we should probably
just power our cars on hopes and dreams
and unicorn juice but for people who are
trying to subsist who are trying to live
we're trying to be pulled out of global
dire poverty they need those tools and
if we say to them no no
no-no-no Bangladeshis you're not allowed
to use oil you know these these are
people who could contract diseases who
could starve who could live in poverty
because of our whims because we think
that the environment is more important
than people's lives than people
flourishing and being able to support
their families they did this in the
United States when the environmentalists
pushed ethanol so they said look we're
gonna start using more corn in our fuel
instead of dinosaur juice instead of
fossil fuels and oil and that'll be
better for the environment what could go
wrong what could possibly go wrong
well what went wrong is that the use of
ethanol drove up corn prices
tremendously by 2011 which is not not
that long after ethanol we'd start
started really using it the price of
corn had risen from two to three dollars
to seven dollars and multiplied per unit
by you know over over 100 percent and
possibly over 200 percent ethanol went
from five to ten percent of the corn
demand to over forty percent in the
United States that has effects and this
is the case with a lot of leftist policy
there are always unintended consequences
when the federal government acts when
the government acts it's easy to say see
it's helping so and so how
uncompassionate of you not to want to
help the little delta smelt anchovies
that most of my fresh water goes to but
there are all of these unintended
consequences and in in this case you're
talking about over a billion
impoverished people around the world
wind solar wave energy comprises under
ten percent of electricity in the OECD
and that's and the only reason it even
comprises that much is because there are
massive subsidies just last year 160
billion dollars worth of subsidies
electricity is almost all in all park
rated through fossil fuels it's
generated by fossil fuels so just to use
the Bangladeshis actually as an example
in Bangladesh a study was done
electrified households when a household
got electricity what that meant was a
21% increase in annual income and a one
and a half percent reduction in poverty
every single year not just well it's not
like they electrify the home and they
get an extra twenty percent of income
and a one-and-a-half percent decline in
poverty as every single year that is a
massive benefit a massive help to their
quality of life
and yet what we have from the
environmentalists there's no who cares
about those starving Bangladeshis what
about the trees what about the what
about the delta smelt but what about
those cute little anchovies no
forgetting those people no those are
like distant people who speak another
language forget about them the anchovies
they're right here in California this
reminds me of when I was in Cuba this of
you you know where people just totally
lose their priorities because I got back
from Cuban I talked to my lefty friends
they said oh how were the cars Oh is it
nice oh that was it there's isn't it so
quaint that they have old cars they have
old cars that are uncomfortable and
barely can still run because they aren't
allowed to have anything else they're
not allowed to have one economic
prosperity and to there is certain
imports and brought products because
they live on a slave Island you know I
even talk to these liberals that I met
these lefties at the Havana Airport and
they said oh isn't it so nice well
that's so nice that they don't need air
conditioner so that like what they don't
need it you know like we in America we
need air conditioner but those Cubans
don't need it yeah they live and like
sweltering misery because they're not
allowed to have it yeah but you don't
need it then if you think that's so
great about you turn off your air
conditioner in the middle of summer in a
Caribbean island no you won't do it it's
a it's a real other ring to borrow the
left-wing
term it's a real looking down at people
like their lessor like they don't
deserve what you deserve like they don't
enjoy what you like there are different
species almost oh no they don't
we'll just they can skip ahead it's a
total missing of priorities and you see
it on the left you see it all the way
from birth to death and everywhere in
between it's the left that's pushing
abortion killing babies it's the left
that is pushing these anti human
policies of prioritizing the Delta smell
- over human beings
and it's the left who's pushing Death
with Dignity we have to kill old people
now they're not having the best time
ever anymore so let's kill them plus
they're using up so plus they're using
up a lot of medical resources most of
your medical spending and life is in the
last six months of your life so let's
just let's just pull the plug early
that's the part they don't say out loud
but they do whisper it to one another
from beginning to end it's an anti human
ideology or coalition of ideologies and
when you sense that when you get a whiff
of that I think that's how you know that
it isn't right in a theological way it's
where you see this sort of mark of the
devil coming around whenever people are
trying to really increase human misery
that way in the name of compassion and
just even in a in a more material and
secular way you you can just see it when
someone wants that the anchovy is to
have a better day than the Bangladeshis
run away from that ideology that's not a
good ideologies and this gets to another
do I have to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube I was just I was gonna explain
the meaning of life can I explain the
meaning of life do I have time for that
okay well well I won't explain the
meaning of life but I will explain why
conservatives find more meaning in life
there's a new study out it's a study out
of UC University of California it was a
study that actually analyzed surveys
from about 16 different countries and it
found a higher life satisfaction and
that conservatives had a found more
meaning in life across the board
conservatives over lefties found more
meaning in life and had more happiness
and had more life satisfaction why is
that well let's just see what the study
say they found that conservative states
were happier than left-wing states even
just within the United States
and one of the reasons for that is that
conservative states are less and
neurotic and having come from New York
and California I can personally attest
to the Oedipus very true
this is according by the way to Gallup
Healthways well-being index the US
Census Bureau CBS News New York Times
poll z' and obviously presidential
election results 2000 to 2008 the the
study also found that that happiness and
finding meaning in life are more likely
related to social issues rather than
economic issues there there I I don't
use the term social issues because all
issues are social issues if it's
political it's social because it's
involved
more than one person but it is cultural
and that is the real crux of it its
cultural and it gets down to the cult it
gets down to what you worship that is
going to determine it I'm not surprised
at all that people who view life as
sacred and who view the human being is
having certain roles in certain
teleology and certain purposes is going
to find more meaning in life and be
therefore happier than people who just
want lower taxes you know if you're
ekiden that's the cool thing to be in
college you know so I'm a social liberal
but a fiscal conservative like I really
don't care about culture at all but I
like me and I like money a lot man you
know puff puff pass that I'm not I'm not
surprised at all to find that this you
you see it all throughout literature you
see it all throughout politics and
history but especially at this moment
with the rise of the nuns the the people
who don't affiliate with any religion
which is taking place almost entirely in
the Democratic Party and on the left
wing of the political spectrum you're
seeing a simultaneous rise but almost 1
for 1 in in suicides in depression I'm
not saying that that's a causation but I
am saying that those two things are
coinciding that they're happening at the
same time and it's it's hard to imagine
that they don't have some relationship
to one another of course it makes sense
if you really believe as prominent left
wingers are trying to tell us and has
become a sort of mainstream view among a
major political party if you really
believe that life has no purpose
you have no inherent dignity you're a
random accidental collection of cells
there's no good there's no evil there's
no love there's no joy it's all just a
trick
it's all just an illusion and the only
the only reason the only the only
momentum you have to keep going is
pleasure just giving yourself pleasure
you're not going to ultimately be
gratified by that you're gonna when the
pleasure turns off then you're gonna
want to turn off to it is a horribly a
dystopic and distressing way to live
through life and conservatives don't
have that conservatives are a buttress
against that one because we're
conservatives tend to be more religious
and two because of the tradition
conservatives tend to be more
traditional and thankfully even when bad
ideas crop up and sort of pervade the
culture the tradition keeps you rooted
as long as you do rituals as long as you
sort of preserve the traditions and
Society you're still going to be
connected to that thing which has some
sanity which has some foundation on the
neurosis I noticed that my conservative
friends broadly speaking or were a lot
less anxious and worried and nervous and
angry all the time and my left-wing
friends they're pulling their hair out
this is true you know when the
Conservatives lose a presidential
election they're unhappy about it
they're not pleased but they don't like
flood into the street and start burning
down cities like the Democrats do they
don't refuse to concede elections as
happened in 2000 as happened in 2016
they do they just sort of they move on
they try to be constructive they try to
channel their frustration into something
better because they have a purpose you
know neurosis is a symptom of narcissism
I say this to my friends all the time in
New York and LA and they're shocked and
horrified but it is it's a symptom of
narcissism it's means that you're
obsessing over yourself all the time
people who are too obsessed with their
personal health what they're eating you
know this month I'm like I'm a Krypto
vegan paleo daily dairy GMO whatever
they're it's narcissism it's because
you're only concerned with yourself and
how every little thing feels on you and
well maybe if I change this you're
treating yourself as an idol you're
treating your body as a machine that
you're worshipping is an idol don't do
that you're not your you're not perfect
and so that's going to leave you not
gratified but when you look outside of
yourself then I think you'll have a bit
much better psychological effect you'll
have more happiness you'll find more
meaning in life and the study by the way
even looked to two different kinds of
happiness not just quality of life you
know well-being smiley smiley pleasure
but also a uu demonic like eudaimonia
the Aristotelian sense of really having
meaning of pursuing a good of pursuing
virtue you you will have more of that
because you're looking outside of
yourself you know a a man wrapped up in
himself makes a small package indeed
look outside of yourself conservatives
are able to do that that's why
conservatives are better at
understanding different people's points
of view that's why the left is much
worse at understanding the right than
the right is at understanding the left
it's why the left will unfriend people
on social media who disagree with them
but the right doesn't do that nearly as
often as the left does there's a little
bit more understanding there's a putting
something outside of yourself don't be a
narcissist and it's fit for it
frequently people who accuse others of
being narcissists you know of saying
like who scream all the time Trump's a
narcissist your you know get in people's
faces really angrily they I think they
have the problem don't they
because narcissism has a meaning it has
it's the excessive love of self of
constantly adoring yourself looking at
yourself all the time
I think it's those I don't think
President Trump is a narcissist I don't
see much evidence of that he might be
crude he might be brash he might be
self-interested but I don't see him as a
narcissist I see him as too blunt and to
too connected to reality for them that's
an important thing you'll you'll your
life will be better rates of depression
rates of anxiety people are popping all
of these meds it's proliferating the
culture don't let it happen to you in
the way that you can do it is just stop
thinking about yourself all the time and
really I think this is just a
rationalization because I don't want to
eat all those healthy diets you know GMO
non GMO and all that but but really I
mean really do it you will be happier
and and hounam you know you'll you'll
you'll be happier both in a sense of
meaning and in and in the pleasures of
your life because you'll be eating a lot
better food okay we I do have to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube now I do
want to get before we go away to this
day in history but I'm sorry if you're
on facebook or youtube go to daily
wire.com why well you'll spend 10 bucks
a month $100 for an annual membership
because we're not like Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes we are capitalists year we want
your money give us your money and we
will give you value you know we'll give
you my show the Andrew Fleming show the
men Shapiro show you can ask questions
in the mailbag get those mailbag
questions and we're doing them tomorrow
you can ask questions in the
conversation but forget that's like a
little bit of value that's like a little
hint of value the real value baby
the leftist here's tumblr this is it the
leftist tears and Jeff Flake tumblr the
leftist and frivolous Republican tumblr
you need them because they're salty
they're delicious they keep pouring out
we're gonna be talking also in the next
week or so about impeachment and why the
left really just probably can't impeach
Trump and then what you were gonna need
to make this like seven sizes bigger
it's gonna have to be like one of those
giant gulps at the at the convenience
store go to daily we're calm we'll be
right back with this day in history
all right in my last minutes here we've
got to talk about parallels in history I
noticed this about history right now
that it all nature has been art unknown
today all chance direction which thou
canst not see there are really weird
coincidences that happen in history
parallels between current events and
things that happened a hundred years ago
or fifty years ago and things that
happened fifteen hundred years ago 2,000
years ago on this day in history in 1940
FDR Franklin Delano Roosevelt Democrat
president and King was nominated for a
third term for president unprecedented
anti-american a really awful move and
sort of set up some of the political
dysfunction that we have around today
also on this day in history in the year
of our Lord 64 Rome burned under Nero
under Emperor Nero that seems
coincidental in that little weird on the
day that the American Republic sort of
caved on its basic Republican image and
Republican self understanding and and a
President Roosevelt broke the example of
George Washington himself first time
American history and decided no I will
be a king until I die I will reign in
this country that's also the day in
history that Rome burned to the ground
how interesting under a terrible Emperor
so FDR FDR is lionized because he faced
difficult challenges to World War two
and the Great Depression and he Abele
handled World War two and he ineptly
handled the Great Depression now it's
difficult to prove a negative but it's
quite clear there been plenty of
economic studies done one recently out
of UCLA to show why the Great Depression
was so prolonged what is such a strange
event they didn't recover very quickly
because of the wage controls that FDR
was instituting you know at one point I
believe FDR set the price of gold
because of his favorite number his lucky
number he just picked it you know that
is not good it's such a horrific
interference into the economy that have
prolonged it for it for a decade but
he's lyin eyes because I said well what
if the country could have collapsed if
not for him I can't prove a negative but
I can't point to clear economic
indicators that he prolong to the
depression but that isn't the real
problem with Roosevelt the problem is
that he spent in the tradition of George
Washington and the and all of his 600 of
Washington's successors and created this
American monarchy he was the American
monarch FDR was a lifelong politician he
ran for New York State Senate at 29
years old then he was governor of New
York then he was elected president in
1932 he decided to run for a third term
unprecedented in 1940 ostensibly under
the guise of patriotism you know war was
launching in Europe and he felt that he
would it would be unpatriotic to have a
normal presidential election cycle while
the war was going on in Europe I don't
know if that's really true is that ever
happened in other wars in the United
States the US had fought plenty of Wars
before that World War one the
spanish-american war a civil war is that
the war of 1812 did we really start
practically suspending presidential
elections or ignore at least ignoring
the custom of George Washington because
of that no it's a ridiculous excuse and
you know it's a ridiculous excuse
because of 1944 he ran again for
president a fourth time in 1944 and was
elected although at that point he was a
thousand years old and died in office
but he didn't need to run in 1944 the
war was already was already basically
over Rome had been liberated the Allies
had landed successfully at d-day Paris
had been liberated the Japanese had been
routed out of Burma the war was going
very well but people don't look at that
they say oh how patriotic he was he was
you know just defending his country in
the war nonsense this was it this guy
was a real threat to democracy pushed
through a lot of anti constitutional
programs he tried to pack the courts I
mean he really tried to end and in many
cases successfully subverted our
constitutional system of government
that's a real threat of Liberty and
that's what I'm talking about when the
left certainly but also when frivolous
conservatives start attacking Trump
because he used the wrong word in
Helsinki because he didn't speak with
Reagan like eloquence in when he was
talking to the Russian dictator and by
the way when Ronald Reagan spoke with
Reagan like eloquence to the Russian
dictator they said the same mean things
about him and they said the same
pointed things about him you've got to
keep your eye on the prize
what we're does the threat to Liberty
lie does the threat to Liberty lie from
President Trump saying a couple wrong
words on cameras and before some
dictator that we've that Americans have
said plenty of nice things about before
that George Bush said nice things about
that Barack Obama said nice things about
and you know deferred to in many foreign
affairs is that were the threat to
Liberty lies or just the threat to
Liberty lies somewhere else in a
bureaucracy of federal bureaucracy
executive agencies lead at times by
crooked figures in the FBI and CIA where
those agencies are overstepping their
constitutional bounds and in some cases
trying to overturn a presidential
election where you've got a commission a
special counsel that drops indictments
strategically time to upset
international relations a basically
unaccountable Special Counsel and
investigation the man with more power in
the world probably than the president
does where does the threat to Liberty
live where does the threat to our
constitutional system lie it doesn't
line a couple strange words from a guy
who's known for using strange words but
who otherwise is preserving Liberty it
lies elsewhere you've got to you know
it's very easy to just throw stones and
attack and try to always be in the
popular position but that's not the
adult thing to do it's a childish thing
to do you've got to preserve Liberty
would he or wouldn't he or woody or that
who cares take yes for an answer keep
pursuing Liberty and to try to prevent
try to prevent tyranny in America where
you can or else we're gonna end up like
what happened to Nero's Rome I get you
on that happy note get your mailbag
questions in for tomorrow so that we can
answer all every single one of them I
know we've been running a little bit
late recently so I'm gonna have to I'm
gonna speed through them tomorrow get as
many answers in as we can
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael an old show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you